[Music]
I'd say the one thing that I utilized
the most right now is the lessons that
we learned that revolve around the I
call it the power of the spoken word the
the things that we say how the things
that we say impact our direction in life
and the outcome of our situations and
one of the earliest times I remember
seeing seeing this work was in first
phase my best friend came to me one day
and he said Chad I don't think I'm good
enough to make it through this training
anymore and you know I had known prior
to that statement that he had been
having some thoughts of doubt but when
he kept those thoughts within his own
head he was able to continue from day to
day but as soon as he came to me that
that morning and spoke it out loud that
statement he created that reality it
became real it crushed him man he was
crushed by that single statement I don't
think I'm good enough and it's in and
shortly after he made that statement he
went in and quit and I thought you know
this guy my buddy you know he was
completely physically capable of doing
everything that we had to do that day
and every single day until graduation
but those words crushed him man it was
like the Rubicon once he once he crossed
that there's no return once you once you
give voice to whatever it is whatever
demon is swimming around in your head it
gives it a gives it a power that you
can't take that there's there's
something about when it's something
about the spoken word man and I think
the the written word has has similar and
equal power but you know a lot of my
stuff lessons revolve around that spoke
in Word and now that's transferred that
lesson has transferred into ultrarunning
and you know I've seen that power of the
spoken word push people beyond their
conceived limits so give me an example
of practicing that so I can give you an
example of how we practice it at a race
a few months ago I we were doing a Last
Man Standing race right so this is one
with Jesse no this was one that I didn't
do the one with Jesse I had done one a
few months before uh-huh so I became
acquainted with a young man named Thomas
Thomas had never ran more than a 10k
race before so she's about six miles and
me and Thomas kind of partnered up and I
thought I'm gonna I'm gonna mentor
Thomas and it starts to get you know
we'd been we had made it to like 15
hours so is it one of those were you do
a loop and you get a break and you have
to do it in a certain way I mean just
keep going until no there's only one
person left yeah six miles every hour on
the hour until was this the race that
you created we we actually hosted a race
that was a similar format but this was
one I was actually competing in okay so
Thomas we get the Sun starts to set and
I you know I look in his eyes and I can
tell he's hurt and bad man he he's he's
he's almost done and I told Thomas I
said Thomas I just want I want you to do
something for me I said I want you to
just say I will never quit and Thomas
looks over at me and he he says I'll
never quit and I'm like no man I want
you to yell it out loud let everyone
around here know that you will never
quit and I think Thomas kind of thought
that it was cocky but it wasn't about
being cocky it was about us creating
this confidence in this reality for
ourselves through the words that we
spoke so Thomas yelled
we'll never quit and then throughout the
rest of that night
every time I'd see Thomas we'd yell back
and forth to each other I'll never quit
Thomas ran over a hundred miles that day
so from a 10k he ran over a hundred
miles do you know what his goal was
going in 200-mile it was to run it was a
hundred miles but you know we had also
made a pact with each other that uh and
and I had I had made this for myself but
I brought Thomas on board that will
never that we wouldn't die in the chair
during that race that we would die out
on the race course when our time came
battling for every step so on Thomas's
last lap he reached his goal and he said
he's sitting in his chair he said
brother Chad he said I got my hundred
miles man I'm good uh-huh and I said naw
Thomas we said we're not dying in the
chair brother
so Thomas Thomas rose up out of the
chair man out of that that he did speak
those words out loud he know you gotta
overcome but maybe it reached his goal
essentially he had every right to be
there but he had just had a little he
forgot about don't die in the chair you
know
so Thomas rises up in and and comes back
out toes the line again and he's running
with me and based essentially waiting
for my permission to to end right and
yeah we get out about 300 yards from the
start line and I say all right Thomas
you did it rather could you could have
withheld that permission just see you
know how much further this guy so proud
man it was amazing so what do you what
do you make of that like what is that
about like how is how is it like that
the spoken word can carry that kind of
power it's you know and and I don't know
I don't know what from
something in your thought that's in your
head hmm it's just a thought it's it's
not tangible to anyone else except for
you but when you speak something out
loud it actually becomes something real
something that can be measured so it
becomes something that's part of this
reality that we live in and and and I
feel like that's what gives it the power
the power of the spoken word I feel like
that's why it's so powerful because as a
thought it's it's essentially it's not
part of this reality that we're living
in but as soon as you speak it it
becomes real
right that's where I find a power at man
so the the practical application of that
or the practice of it is to be very
measured or judicious and what comes out
of your mouth and to be careful that
that to be mindful of the words that you
speak such that whatever is coming out
of your mouth is is you know a positive
affirmation that underscores the the
goal that you're trying to achieve I
think you have to be constant constantly
conscious of it man and and it's that
something I practice in my own life and
you know I obviously I take it kind of
some people would think to the extreme
you know I don't curse that's not a I'm
a Christian but that's not a Christian
thing it's because none of those words
in and of themselves have a positive
meaning so I try to stay constantly in
control of my rudder I look at my tongue
as my do you ever [ __ ] that up
oh yeah I mean everybody's gonna make
mistakes man for sure but you know a big
thing rich is to be especially aware of
your rudder during times of adversity
right you know because that's when
that's when it really matters when
you're in the struggle when you're in
the furnace of adversity that's when you
have to be really conscious of the
things that you're saying yeah in my
opinion back to Budds was there ever a
breaking moment
were you or were you just and and was
this kind of perspective taught to you
or you just this was an intuitive thing
that you stumbled upon as a survival
mechanism to get through this it so it
wasn't all I think it's been it was an
intuitive thing but I think that it's
also developed now through you know as I
get older and I continue to see at work
and I teach these skills to other people
and then I hear their testimonies when
they come back and say oh my gosh you
know I was in this terrible situation or
this terrible moment and I just spoke
life into my situation and it changed
the direction it changed the outcome
those things all strengthened my faith
in these actual tools that we have right
in Budds there was no breaking point for
me though there was never a time that I
thought about that I thought about
quitting never a single moment I never
looked toward the Bell and and again
that's not because I'm any tougher than
anyone else man but it's because I had
been through a furnace of adversity
prior to even toeing the line so I had
quite a bit invested right so you get
through that and then what where and
what was your deployment like like what
was the experience of actually being a
Navy SEAL so you know I did multiple
deployments over the course of the 12
years that I was active duty as far as
the experience of being a Navy SEAL man
it's not as sexy as you would think it's
I'll tell you the best part about being
a Navy SEAL as you get to go to work
with heroes every single day you get to
go to work with these men that are just
you know have integrity these men that
just will not quit and you get to be
surrounded by those people every day
that was the best part of actually being
in the SEAL Teams as far as the
day-to-day job it's a job man yeah you
you know you have a mission every day
whether it's training or you know actual
mission and you're a professional you're
an operator and you get the job done and
it's not you know buddy there's doing it
for glory
at least not you know there may be your
odd ball every now and then that that
that's the why they do it but you're
real operators are are just there to get
a job done that needs to be done man
[Music]